[Música]
[Aplausos]
como seria sua vida se fosse para saber se
está tudo bem desde a adolescência
aqui a bilheteria teve um efeito diferente
tomou outras decisões sofreu
menos, por favor, sólidos de fissão e pense
um pouco o seguinte
--equipes precisavam conhecer os 15
anos inning sim não
ward nessa resposta pode abrir
osorios um modelo de peso de pássaro em seu
seguido com carro próprio casa própria
e eu não tenho um estado, eles não correspondem mais
mais as necessidades de muitas pessoas
tem a ver com este alguém que tinha
pensou ou já tinha decidido largar tudo
estudar algo completamente
diferente, mas em um mundo ou realizar um
sonho de infância acordei mal
mais de um mês de satisfação porque você tem
tanta gente insatisfeita
denotado para gestar, mas suas vidas são
vários em nosso sistema educacional
realidade que não é um país nem uma escola
eles conseguem dar conta da educação
jovens muitos deles muitos países
passam 8 horas trabalhando milho ou maduro
horas sem trânsito e quando ainda estão em casa
estão muito cansados ​​ou não têm tempo
para sindicalizar eles atingem duas bordas e scola
que está vazio de um modelo que também
não atende nossas necessidades
os seres humanos também não
oferecer a educação que precisamos
precisamos dessa educação
fundamentalmente para essa coisa de resposta é
acho que algo agora sobre equipes é
precisamos conhecer os 15 anos sem nenhum
link se não for provável essa resposta
isso já está relacionado com a sua felicidade e
presente ou ausência do talvez com o qual
uma pessoa está feliz e outra não
e parece que você pode aprender a ser feliz
e se scola eu pudesse se ele nos ensinasse a ser
feliz é mais como alocar algo do que
galpão muito varia muito de pessoa para pessoa
outra é dizer uma ferramenta em
coaching chamado aj dá vida sob
toda a vida é baseada em filosofias
Oriental e o apresenta uma forma de
vencer a felicidade e o ser humano
o eu tenho oito elementos do
intelecto saúde e vida financeira amigos
e família trabalho e carreira
problema de espiritualidade e amor
escola tradicional que se baseia
em apenas dois ou três dos seus elementos
trabalho e carreira e eu não os dois
laser e intelecto
um mais requintado de seus elementos ainda
espiritualidade mais importante do que não
é equivalente à religião já deve
conhecer alguém muito religioso e
muito pouca espiritualidade espiritual já
tem que ver o sentido da vida com
conexão que eles se opõem como maior com
sentimento de 1260 e príncipe ou quando
concordou que amanhã encontra prazer
com você com sua vida e egos
Táxis
a espiritualidade de ter com
auto-estima como a própria bússola
interior com uma conexão com o meio ambiente
em harmonia e com esse sentimento de
plenitude
em busca da felicidade que deu início ao
a maioria de nós falta
responde a falta de orientação
questões espirituais vêm muitas
crise na adolescência naquela época e
como fazer perguntas do tipo show do rei
O que eu quero será a costa de alguém
eu porque em aumento já porque nasci
naquela família com seus pais que não
alguem nao tem nada a ver comigo
aí surgem essas crises e capacidade
Com essas crises, adolescentes e
quando você é os padrões não se encaixam
o que é socialmente aceitável e
instabilidade do agente soft frame muitos dos
ele e são diagnosticados com
distúrbios psiquiátricos, como depressão
ansiedade ataques de pânico
na escola expulso da escola ou
se eu virar objetos de bullying e assim
ficamos com a infelicidade e um
adolescência como se fosse um apetite e
precisa menina agressão erradicada para
educação tentou incorporar um pouco
dessas negociações de que estamos a falar
que estamos trazendo aqui a palavra
scola designada a laser são os pesos
que não precisava trabalhar e
escola pré-escolar no intervalo
que ônibus por dia quando você nos deu
quando você queria ser divertido é o seu
primeiro problema scola argentino
educação eddy merckx certamente é
objetivo é formar um ser humano com
plena harmonia e autocontrole
prepará-lo para a cidadania e lição de casa
cívico na cidade onde é um lugar de
diversa uma escola porque a Argentina
Eles se divertiram em uma escola universitária
em outro valeu a pena porque já está esperando
fim de semana para chegar para poder
divertir
escola aprendemos a não expressar o que
que sentimos para competir com nossos
colegas para excluir tem diferente e para
passar algum tempo todos fazendo algo caiu
Deus chinês está estudando coisas que nós
fazer sentido na união para nós e assim
que a escola nos prepara para
infelicidade e um mercado de trabalho
palavra educar já antecipa patches e
problemas
educar vendula ching e meios
dirigir para dirigir para
de
a palavra entregue aos sentidos e
peso preparado para o promundo mas trabalho
a constituição brasileira de que falamos
educação que sentido educação visual
cheio desse movimento de pessoas para
um exercício que uma cidadania fez
qualificação, mas trabalhou novamente ou
ênfase está no exterior
levou a pessoa para fora de si mais
jogo significativo de preparar as pessoas
promundo quando os inda não se conhecem
o que falta na educação na solidão
para dentro ou auto-conhecimento existem
algumas escolas tentando sair
sim padrón de sua casa um homem infeliz já é
Já existem várias iniciativas de interesse
Sánchez um problema que muitos desses
escolas atraem uma minoria
população porque para começar com poucos
países estão cientes disso
situação e poucos deles são
louco o suficiente para aumentar
filis para uma escola mais experiente
também temos um problema nesses
emiliano iniciou as escolas é o
mesma classe social e chini à realidade
que um mundo não é assim então
escolano mostra essa realidade também
essas escolas precisam cumprir
requisitos de um ministério da educação
[Música]
estão vazios em alguma religião da imprensa ou
ser abordado em pedagogia pedagogica
específico que orienta e ao mesmo tempo
limita a liberdade e ambos os professores
com quanto dois alunos trabalham
educação 15 anos como gelo e 15 anos
ele treina scola 24 anos e nunca mais disse
na área lateral na china quando a china des
oitenta anos e apenas dar a fase franca de
formatura depois de linda para se formar
doutorado na inglaterra ou nos eua
por seu ouro e vários anos a
universidade ajudando salas de aula fazendo
garota de pesquisa procurando por felicidade e meu
família deixar um estudo do mundo inteiro
muito o que eu uso percebe o que eu
estava tentando não era nem em Londres nem em
paris nem os livros muito mais tarde o
Passei por várias experiências que aprendi
muitas dessas propriedades esses cursos que
estão sendo postados no facebook e no
qualquer o que de qualquer maneira todos todos
todo o meu dinheiro foi para todos
terapias alternativas que existem
mesa estranha escritório menina tudo que você
você você tira mais nunca o suficiente
também precisava de algumas tampas
face do universo eles sabem que o palco
um estágio de karnak fará o universo e
quando você é o homem sábio que você tem que enfrentar ou
que eu tenho que deixar o diff fazer mais sem cara
nada e continuar fazendo a mesma coisa
universo vem pode
então antes
o passeio e vários
mas foi assim que aprendi com as experiências e
até para obter minha conexão comigo
mim mesmo e reconhecer meu propósito de vida
que mostrou prosieben show para o
pessoas à luz que a Espanha dentro
sim e assim beijo meu papel de educador
em mostrar às pessoas os talentos que
ferir um brilho adequado e conformar
eles estão aprendendo a descobrir e
óleo aqueles poderes que ele também reconhece
os e-mails em Reafirmo a mídia e assim por diante
Esse professor trabalha por um tempo
de volta eu escrevi um sonho acredite em mim scola que
carvalhos e toda aquela escola tradicional
sem azinheira e foi assim que ele nasceu se casou
presenteie em casa o seu presente em um
escola co criada por Robbins e
profissionais de diversas áreas
o embrião que questiona aquele escritório
processo que os 15 queriam que soubéssemos
anos neste país nós reunimos uma multidão
da juventude três dias de xenofobia não
se perguntarmos por ele é que você
Eu gostaria que uma escola fosse diferente
quais ônibus você gostaria de aprender
É um menino que você me machucou para participar de um
hackathon educacional um hackathon
geralmente uma maratona que reúne
programadores e outros profissionais
tecnologia para desenvolver software
que realmente responde a algum tipo de
problema para resolver um problema
um chinês criou um software nós criamos um
modelo ocasional com novas formas
aprender e novos conteúdos e senti
falo para o projeto final de um hackathon
Eu não sei lutar eles fazem cabras e se reproduzem
dessa escola e as vozes devem ser
convidado a fundir salas de aula eu sei gigas
e foi assim com o desejo dos alunos de
diferentes classes sociais em são paulo
trabalhará por seis horas para criar
esta escola é a escola dos sonhos
coisas molhadas que foram apresentadas a ele foram
valores porque faltavam agentes é
cansado de regras as regras não são fáceis
sentido um ano para não é uma escola
porque somos um dia todos a pé duplo
pois ele a usa entre quatro paredes e é
aprendendo coisas que fazem sentido para nós
por que somos forçados a gastar tanto
papel porque somos todos aliados
da mesma forma que você aumenta você encontra
diferenças de cada um então e truque
regras por valores
mesmo todo mundo tem que ser capaz
participe você mesmo não se engane
autenticidade que foi importante ou foi
pode ser você mesmo a escola não é
não só o 1 professor também tem que
poder ser o mesmo sem medo de ser
colaboração censurada compartilhar arrependimento
porque competir com colegas se opôs
aprender a colaborar com ele e
compartilhar algum conhecimento
sustentabilidade que era muito difícil
porque nos tornamos mais realistas e não
nós temos essa dificuldade que eu pretendo
adaptar a certos hits certos
pratica a participação ou então
modificar a escola em um papel de peso
a passiva que recebi conhecimento ou fui
ter participado ser ativo no
aprendizagem processo de aprendizagem
espontaneidade se você tem como professor
planos ou como a atividade é percebida
outra coisa acontece é sempre mente fais la
da mesma forma se um aluno propõe um
atividade diferente porque você também pode
assegurar que a espontaneidade
mostrar a maioria das escolas
prejudiciais 6 mais quando eram de camundongos não
Baby, eu estava sempre pensando que não quero
fazer depois que ele saiu
scola fez essa presença faltar
está aqui sem uma sala de aula augusto evo
pensa em outra coisa então
experiências na escola têm e são
organizado por trás da pressão
mas apresentar curiosidade não podemos
matar a curiosidade dos jovens
escola temos que incentivar
curiosidade não foi a próxima pausa não
não podemos falar de favor para aqueles que se importam
o espaço para a autonomia da curiosidade
isso foi interessante vários tiros
para pessoas que aprendem a ser autônomas
depender de outras pessoas para a fase de
qualquer coisa, por exemplo, consignar por
exemplo cocar sofrido eles não querem
ser dependente e finalmente amar isso
um valor interessante porque quando
tenha amor quando a josefa for qualquer
recebido com amor provavelmente
trabalhar para todos os outros valores que
aqui está algo que surgiu em oaxaca
ton foi que nós estudamos e fazemos
precisamente para que todos
poderia participar com nossos alunos
criamos escolas ellis durante o
semana e finais de semana e
Participe das atividades em casa
presidente e por ele nos fez uma turma em
uma pilhagem da sociedade que eu tenho
pessoas de classe média e alta
comunidade da periferia e temos antes
alguns refugiados da África e da Síria
nos faz o diabo mudo toda a semana e
daí eles compram içou ela significativa
e isso é triste contextualizado não e
sozinho no conteúdo e sozinho fora
contexto para a experiência alimentar
saudável para conter sem uma aorta e um
experiência de ioga de costela acontece um
espaço de meditação yoga também
compartilhamento de mente e colaboração
com o trabalho e a interculturalidade e num
mesquita centro de são paulo
conteúdos também são escolhidos para
jovens e trabalham em uma
interdisciplinar, por exemplo
experiência de alimentação saudável
nós também temos um momento
de empreendedorismo não setor de
gastronomia e também uma meditação
da dúvida orta uma experiência de
ginecologia natural las meninas também
sala de trabalho na parada de prática pública
Diga coisas um pouco mais delicadas e também
sem intervalos plugs mais verifique com
leguminosas orgânicas são tocadas las meninas
nossos professores vêm das mais
diversas áreas temos atualmente 20
forma que eu venho para todos
professores parecem indiferentes e você você
convencional primeiro produz ser
professor post em que eu amo que você é
fácil e tranquilo da noite para o dia e ele é
o caso com ele e eles são adorados, embora ele
ele é jovem por isso ou papel de lis
de professores em mais do que inventores e
facilitadores e dança vêm ao seu
trabalho que é fácil para eles durante o
experiências que os organizam, por exemplo
das minas indianas agora que criarão
próprias empresas
Eu tenho um vinil que foi contratado
como ilustrador para uma empresa de logotipos
do itavu leiro e tenho três minas que
eles acabaram de gravar os primeiros cinco em
estúdio de gravação e agora eu senti que valia
gravar um clipe e iniciar o y
também redes sociais então que
Foi graças aos professores e a um
trabalho frito com amor segundo
urso mestre espiritual
educação deve ser responsabilidade
da comunidade e não só dos países
quando a comunidade me responsabilizo não só
espiões para relacionamento um vídeo country é diluído
a referência quando é trocado com tantos
pessoas se torna compartilhada causou
presença tenta fazer um pouco de fase e vai
aproximar-se das pessoas que amam
aprendem quando querem ensinar isso
que sempre priorizou acontecer
rastreia um lado do professor próprio
experiência transformou aprender algo
é feito de duas maneiras é com
Desejo que você começou a criação do
casa do presente quando os professores
estamos tentando inventar um nome
falhou presente imagine essa cena um
grupo de excelentes profissionais para
com corridas muito impressionantes
todos eles se registram tentando criar um nome
chocante não conseguia pensar em nada
remotamente sem
poderíamos uma lista de nomes em gorduras
eles tiveram sua experiência e agora é sobre
nunca houve china chinesa
ofilio de uma os professores eram os
liguei para celulares e escolha os e aposte
droga é hora de Lucas missiva falsa é
ligue sem escola
casado apresente seu presente porque para
aprender com quais vozes eles precisam aprender
sinar agora e não em um futuro que haja
não existe no presente porque um
presente que você tem para oferecer
pressão e necessidade de ligar para casa e não
É fila porque é um lugar para todos e
um lugar que você gosta e fico
[Música]
educação precisa mostrar prós
jovem na luz que a caneca dentro do
cinema porque o já é o
--equipes necessárias para aprender em 15
anos os jovens precisam aprender agora
as equipes precisam aprender agora
obrigada
[Aplausos]